you're a family man yeah now and last
year this picture went around because
you is this at comic-con did you go to
comic-con where'd you do it this was a
comic-con I actually got a matte suit
and a little baby gas mask the previous
time I was at comic-con years ago right
and I brought out a fake baby Halle on
stage and it was actually when we were
wrapping up the show and I asked my can
I keep this little meth suit right for
my unborn baby right and are you what
you're having a baby well not yet but
eventually I'll have a baby like yeah
sure you can have it
right and so cut to next time I was at
Comic Con it fit my baby and I thought
it was appropriate so here we go here
you are with that's a picture she'll
treasure forever
Wow chubby leg a man what a little chunk
yeah yeah you don't have kids you should
they're the best and you should put them
in meth lab